shirin chashu tries to forget the pain
suffered under years of isil rule
it's a hard task isil fighters used her
as a sex slave
causing deep physical and emotional
scars
an estimated seven thousand yazidi women
and girls were taken from sinjar
many had to endure what shirin went
through she's found her sons after isil
lost its last territory in syria
but her two daughters are still missing
i miss my daughter so much i would give
my life if i could see them again
it's hard for her sons to readjust as
they've forgotten their language and
feel disconnected from the yazidi
culture
but one of her most painful memories is
when shireen lost her husband in sinjar
they dug a hole in the backyard killed
and dumped several bodies
we saw it in kojo town behind the trench
we saw many dead bodies i couldn't go to
see my husband
i was banned from reaching that place
they killed many people that day
five years since the yazidis were
targeted by isil mass graves are still
being uncovered
a special united nations investigative
team to promote accountability for
crimes committed by isil
called unitad is currently examining
evidence
while most families in this camp are
yazidis the u.n body investigating isil
war crimes says that sunnis
shias everyone suffered under isil
and unitad is trying to hold isil
accountable for the crimes it committed
the unmandated investigative body says
it's making progress
we've had some very you know major
successes
in terms of uh receiving information and
evidence we have
600 000 plus videos now we have
received information from government
authorities
and best practices were needed for
ensuring that evidence was collected in
a way that it could be preserved
and it could be admissible
in different courts in different parts
of the world
a forensic lab has been set up to test
dna samples from mass graves
experts are seeking more funding to
improve and expedite their work
the director told us that matching dna
samples is a complicated task
it requires comparing samples from mass
graves with victims families
some are still in syria and many others
are living abroad
we're looking for missing bodies and
most are in mass graves located in
remote areas
these places are full of landmines and
it gets very
hot in areas like sinjar and the staff
can only work during
early hours of the morning
regardless of the challenges involved
thousands of yezidis and camps like this
one want justice
and even though they want to move on
with their lives many like sharing don't
want to return to their homes in sinjar
she says the place has horrible memories
and she'd rather wait to be reunited
with her daughters
as long as that may take osama
the hook